the german government says it is
preparing for possible attacks on
coronavirus vaccination centers
vaccine shipments or vaccine makers now
according to the interior ministry there
is a quote abstract threat of sabotage
on germany's vaccination campaign in a
letter the ministry said
vaccination opponents and conspiracy
theorists could try to break into
facilities or launch
cyber attacks now german vaccine
manufacturers have already been targeted
on several occasions by hackers
attempting to steal intellectual
property
for more on the story we can bring in
our political correspondent emanuel
asha's here in berlin she's following
the latest hi
emma this sounds serious i mean how
dangerous is the situation
well it is a very serious situation
indeed and german authorities warned
against the high risk of for example
cyber attacks
against a research-sized production
sites or vaccination
centers they say also that they've
identified
already some individuals responsible for
such hackings and beyond that they also
worry
about the the the protests that are
taking
a place organized by uh coroner virus
uh skepticals by anti-vaxxers they fear
that those protests could
could go get out of hand the way they
for example went out of hand on a
political
level at the capitol in the united
states so there's a very serious
uh threat here in germany that the whole
vaccination a
rollout might be at a risk
because of that but as you mentioned
authorities are so confident that
they're on top of things right now
okay so authorities say they're
monitoring the situation meanwhile
officials here in berlin have shut down
an entire hospital
after identifying cases of the new
mutation of
covid19 we'll talk about that in a
moment emma but first let's take a look
at this report the humboldt clinic in
berlin
where more than 1 500 staff and 400
patients are in quarantine
the hospital will not be admitting any
new patients for at least a fortnight
it's not nice for the patients they
aren't allowed any visitors
i am sad my daughter is inside she's
waiting for food and drinks but i can't
go in
the closure comes after 14 patients and
six staff members tested positive for
the highly contagious
neukovit 19 strain that originated in
the uk
staff who tested negative are in a
so-called shuttle quarantine
only allowed to travel between work and
home but testing of all patients and
staff
is ongoing
the first results are starting to come
in and we are not optimistic
we hope to have a better overview of the
situation in the coming
hours and days but we can already see
that the number of cases is increasing
up to the industry the humboldt clinic
is considered exemplary
it is one of the only clinics in berlin
that has been testing for the mutation
since the start of the year
it was only because we did a preliminary
screening of positive tests
that the new virus strain came to our
attention and we could act accordingly
to protect the population
as well as our employees and patients
despite their quick action there is
great concern that the new virus variant
will still spread uncontrollably
both in berlin and the rest of germany
a mother's hospital has been sealed off
and that means that staff is being
shuttled between work
and home but that does still mean that
they would be in contact with other
people
there will be but that just shows you
just how difficult it is to
prevent essential workers from actually
doing their work this is impossible we
need doctors we need nurses so they do
have to commute from home to work but
for that the government also
made uh their put at their disposal
shuttle buses so as to avoid
as much as possible that those people
come in contact with the general
publication for example
population sorry for example in public
transport
and bring us up to date on the overall
situation right now in germany
well authorities are very worried about
the new variant
of the virus it said uh that's a
virologist a christian
drawstring from the charity hospital who
confirms
that it is say that this vibrant variant
is
35 more contagious more infectious
than uh the the virus that we currently
now know and in germany there's been
tighter border checks
implemented on sunday this might mean
that there's going to be
some impact on fresh food import
in germany there's also additional
controls implemented in airports
on people coming back from high risk
areas now on the situation regarding the
virus there's
less infections registered today and
less deaths and also a seven days
incidence rate that is still decreasing
there's 111
cases per hundred thousand inhabitants
but that's still two times higher than
the critical
uh threshold the vaccination rollout is
still ongoing with 1.5 million people
vaccinated
at the moment and also a new medicine
has been will be implemented that this
is a new antibody
medicine that will be given to patients
so as to avoid that they develop
severe symptoms from the coronavirus our
political correspondent emanuel asha's
with the latest here
in berlin good to talk to you
now the first nationwide curfew in the
netherlands since world war
ii has sparked widespread rioting unrest
flared up in the capital
amsterdam and the southern city of
eindhoven at least 30 demonstrators
opposing tighter coronavirus
restrictions were arrested
thousands of rule breakers have also
been fined
anger boils over against the night
curfew
the first in 75 years
[Applause]
[Music]
on the streets of eindhoven protesters
set a car on fire
and then rampaged through shops and the
train station
this demonstration in amsterdam is
illegal but
residents are furious at the months-long
lockdown and now the new curfew
live free think and think
freely
they say their freedom and future are
being sacrificed in the fight against
the virus
i don't agree with the restrictions on
freedom
it's certainly true that elderly people
are vulnerable
but there are also so many young people
involved
and young people are the future
this is a voice that is saying no
we are so afraid we're going in the
wrong direction
it may be understandable but it's still
the wrong way
the government says the curfew is a
preventative measure
the number of new positive tests had
been falling
but prime minister mark rutter warned
against a possible surge of infections
from the british mutation
of the virus hours after the curfew came
into force
this is all that's left of a covid
testing center on the coast
and in amsterdam riot police break up a
mostly peaceful demonstration with water
cannons
the netherlands was one of the last eu
countries to begin
immunizing health workers with
production delays slowing vaccination
programs across europe
a return to freedom here and elsewhere
still looks a long way off
in brazil thousands of people have
joined a second day of nationwide
protests calling for the removal of
president jair bolsonaro
over his handling of the pandemic the
national coronavirus death toll stands
at more than
200 000 the second highest in the world
vaccine shortages are holding back
immunizations
and public anger over the worsening
situation is growing
alice gomesh is desperate her mother
needs a ventilator
but the ones in the hospital are all
taken now
doctors aren't giving her much hope
all i want is for my mother to have a
chance
relatives don't get much information the
clinic is totally packed and
overburdened
intensive care beds are full oxygen has
been in short supply for at least a week
hundreds of people wait for hours to
refill tanks so that their loved ones at
home will be able to breathe
the second wave of coronavirus has hit
manaus hard
and the virus has mutated as many as 200
victims are being buried every day
that's seven times more than before the
pandemic
doctors say government inaction is to
blame
the collapse could have been averted
the more the virus can multiply
unchecked
the more likely it is there will be
mutations
in rio de janeiro life continues rather
carefree
perhaps because the president downplays
the virus and publicly doubts the safety
of vaccines
in the meantime people are getting
inoculated
bolsonaro's political opponents exerted
a lot of pressure
and made their own deals with
manufacturers people are protesting
against bolsonaro because of the erratic
rollout of vaccinations
they say he has to go
now to some other developments in the
pandemic mexican president andres manuel
lopez obrador says he has tested
positive for covet 19.
that announcement comes as this country
registers the highest levels of
infections and deaths
to date israel will close its
international airport to nearly all
flights in a bid to bring a raging
outbreak in the country
under control and egypt has started
vaccinating its population
using the chinese-made sino-farm shot
healthcare workers and people with
chronic diseases are among the first in
line
to receive the vaccine
you